de curieuses formes sont apparus à la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
la plasticienne viviane famille et a
nommé son installation à l'intersection
à travers ces textiles entremêlés
l'artiste souhaite transmettre des
émotions je travaille sur la notion de
d'émotions et de sensations donc tout
mon travail se fonde sur la la
perception que moi j'ai de ma chambre de
mes sensations et mes émotions et la
retranscription plastique de ses
émotions initialement son oeuvre
invitait les visiteurs à toucher ces
matières mais il a fallu s'adapter on
travaille de manière générale et tactile
intégralement donc évidemment avec
l'occident n'a pas pu être possible tout
ce travail a été repensé pour qu'il soit
le vide cinglé l'installation est liée à
celle d'un autre artiste nicolas henry
le photographe plasticien et metteur en
scène il présente cabane imaginaire et
esprits de la nature son travail
artistique se construit en deux étapes
d'abord il réalise des interviews des
personnes qu'ils rencontrent au cours de
ses voyages
ensuite il met en scène l'histoire de
ces individus et les photographies à
partir de leur histoire qui soit une
histoire personnelle ou
communautaires ou là où l'histoire de
leur pays en fait j'ai cru de mise en
scène avec les objets que je trouve
autour de ces deux expositions se
rejoignent au sein d'une même thématique
c'est l'humanité l'être humain et il se
trouve que même si les deux les lieux de
travail présentés sont extrêmement
différents ça parle de ça des êtres
humains d'intimité du rapport aux autres
un vernissage est prévu le 12 février
prochain pour l'occasion viviane sagnier
interprétera une performance dansée au
coeur de son installation